à tous les jours j'écoute la musique
dans le métro dans l'autobus juste
l'esprit ambiant et ça me forcément
monter le volume donc c'est sûr qu'ils
adoptaient de la meilleure chose
pareille peu importe où vous regardez il
y en a partout des écouteurs des casques
d'écouté des gens plongés dans leur
bulle musicale fort non mais beaucoup
oui énormément même
ça doit être comme cinq six heures par
jour selon statistique canada
80% des jeunes canadiens portent
quotidiennement des dispositifs de kout
qu'ils utilisent au moins huit heures
par semaine dont trois heures à volume
élevé mais c'est à leurs risques et
périls
savez vous que vous posez oui mon
téléphone mais la fiche qui est comme
quoi tient un danger avec le volume trop
fort et je le fais quand même parce que
la musique est bonne
le problème le plus fréquent un
acouphène c'est souvent un seul incident
comme celui-ci il est produit par le
cerveau et seule la personne qui en
souffre peut l'entendre aujourd'hui 46 %
des jeunes canadiens déclarent avoir eu
au moins un épisode de coûts fans de
pionnat même leurs aînés en eau moins
fréquemment
alors que ça devrait tout le contraire
même ici au chemin sera encore que dans
la tranche d'âge de à peu près 20 40 à
notre clientèle qui consultent pour des
acouphènes problématiques d'accès doublé
dans les dernières années je le
présentais des fréquences à droite que
tu me dis quand tu entends qu est la
cause précise d'un acouphène est encore
mal connue
les audiologistes savent qu'un volume
sonore très élevé et constant est
l'ennemi numéro 1 du système auditif
quand on entend la musique de quelqu'un
qui est dans le métro à côté de nous là
à travers ses écouteurs c'est un think
au tympan à son tympan à cette personne
c'est trop fort des effets des
agressions sonores sont également
cumulatif pour avoir une écoute
sécuritaire qui recommande à la
littérature c'est 60% du volume 60
minutes par jour et ce qui est important
de savoir c'est que si on augmente un
peu l'intensité on doit diminuer de
beaucoup le temps d'exposition
quand il a eu son premier acouphènes
jean-françois de rite est un début de
vingtaine quand il se rend compte que
c'est irrécupérable enfin que ne peut
pas ramener à la en arrière alors
logiquement c'est difficile aujourd'hui
il enseigne la musique
il voit bien que ces étudiants ne
comprennent pas ce qui les attend s'ils
ne changent pas leurs habitudes
je vous dirais qu'au quotidien gère bien
sommet dans un moment de fatigue
d'alexis et et ça fait là sa fin de
boucle
c'est un cube soit des acouphènes
les acouphènes d'être anxieux donc ça je
le gère bien mais est-ce que je vais
encore assez loin
je vois pas ça les spécialistes eux
parlent d'un véritable problème de santé
publique qui prend rapidement de
l'ampleur ces jeunes-là qui raffole des
acouphènes maintenant ils vont vieillir
donc quand il m'accuse vont en avoir
encore plus c'est plus chronique est
plus un commodat donc probablement ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal